[Música]
en la casa de mi abuela en buenos aires
había una habitación que normalmente
estaba cerrada un día yo tendría unos
ocho años abrí la puerta de ese cuarto
misterioso por primera vez y me encontré
con una biblioteca que ocupaba todas las
paredes ahí desordenados en los estantes
había versiones para chicos de las mil y
una noches' la odisea
las aventuras de tom sawyer eran libros
que ya nadie leía y que poco a poco fui
abriendo
estos libros tenían entre las páginas
flores secas cromos y migas de galletita
tenían los márgenes manchados por dedos
llenos de mermelada y estos libros sobre
todo tenían olor a hierbas a chocolate
al fondo de un armario quizás ustedes
también tengan un recuerdo asociado al
olor de los libros es uno de los olores
que nos conmueven es importante para
nosotros en un mundo que nos pide ver
primero y hablar después y es que desde
la modernidad el sentido del olfato ha
sido poco valorado
quizás porque la naturaleza invasiva de
los olores atenta contra nuestra forma
de vida que aprecia la privacidad y la
contención de las emociones de hecho en
la jerarquía moderna de los sentidos la
vista es el método principal que
utilizamos para interactuar con el
entorno esto es válido para nuestra vida
diaria y también para cuando visitamos
museos galerías de arte o casas
históricas que son los ámbitos en los
que trabajo decíamos que el olfato es un
sentido poco valorado pero no por eso
los olores dejan de tener importancia en
nuestra vida diaria de hecho tienen un
impacto enorme sobre la forma en que
pensamos en la que sentimos y en la que
nos comportamos por ejemplo sabían que
cuando entramos a una tienda y
percibimos un olor en el ambiente este
influencia nuestra decisión de compra e
incluso si decidimos volver o no a la
tienda y no son sólo los olores
agradables los que influye en nuestro
comportamiento hace unos años una
empresa inglesa aseguró que rociando las
cuentas por cobrar con él
ahora sudor masculino lograba que se
pagaran más rápidamente
pero volvamos a los libros este olor
junto con muchos otros forma parte de
nuestro patrimonio porque dicen algo
sobre la forma en la que vivimos y las
cosas que nos resultan importantes por
ejemplo en 2001 el gobierno japonés
invitó a sus ciudadanos a votar por sus
olores favoritos para preservar los
lugares donde existían y legar los al
futuro el resultado es una lista de 100
lugares que incluye bosques destilerías
de sake y templos que huelen a incienso
los franceses también entienden la
relevancia de los olores para el
patrimonio por eso han postulado a la
región de graz conocida como la capital
mundial del perfume a candidata a
patrimonio intangible de la humanidad
para proteger las tradiciones asociadas
con el cultivo de flores y la creación
de perfumes
lamentablemente estos son ejemplos
aislados si bien muchos países tienen
estrategias para proteger sus edificios
históricos y sus obras de arte no hay
ningún proyecto sistemático para
proteger olores con valor cultural
tampoco existe un lugar donde podamos
acceder a estos olores no hay un archivo
de olores lo más parecido sea quizás las
botellas de versalles que estamos viendo
donde un grupo de perfumistas conserva
más de 4.000 perfumes les recomiendo que
la visiten aunque sea para oler un
perfume que tiene más de 3000 años es el
perfume de los reyes partos que se
esparcía antes de los banquetes para
abrir el apetito o si prefieren las
emociones fuertes porque no qatar un
olor que cuya fuente ahora está
prohibida en la unión europea'
se trata del almizcle auténtico que se
usaba como fijador de perfumes y se
extrae de los testículos de un ciervo
como decíamos los mote acá es un museo
muy valioso pero se ocupa de perfumes no
de olores y así llegamos al problema los
olores son por naturaleza efímeros
si no los registramos desaparecen por
esto nos llegan del pasado objetos pero
no olores podríamos decir que el pasado
no huele hoy la tecnología nos permite
acceder a las colecciones de museos sin
tener que visitarlos por ejemplo les
muestra una foto que se pierde en esa
transición a lo digital qué cualidades
de los objetos y espacios quedan en el
camino sonidos texturas atmósferas
olores sobre todo olores esta es una de
las habitaciones de 'nole' una de las
casas históricas donde trabajo en
inglaterra a qué huele nos resulta
difícil imaginarnos ahí pero no podemos
hablarlo yo les cuento huele a canela a
rosas y a hierbas es un perfume diseñado
especialmente para este espacio en 1750
es el olor del popurrí una mezcla de
flores secas sales y hierbas preparado
para perfumar el ambiente que se ponía
en unos boles para que se dispersara por
la estancia
un poco en el siglo 18 el popurrí estaba
de moda un poco como hoy pondríamos una
vela aromática encendida en casa este
olor sutil nos habla de un modo de vida
de una forma de entender la relación
entre el exterior y el interior
la idea era atraer el jardín dentro
también nos habla de una tradición de
perfumería doméstica que se está
perdiendo decíamos antes que el pasado
no huele pero cuando un olor se pierde
lo que perdemos es mucho más que un olor
y estamos en peligro también de perder
una parte importante de nuestro presente
el patrimonio del futuro a medida que
las fuentes de estos olores desaparecen
como los libros que se publican solo en
versión digital que podemos hacer para
evitarlo como proteger estos olores para
legar los a futuras generaciones estas
preguntas son el motor de mi trabajo me
han llevado a ocuparme de olores tan
diferentes como el olor de los libros
viejos o el olor del popurrí y a qué me
refiero cuando digo ocuparme primero
y esos olores que puedan tener un valor
cultural no todos los olores viejos lo
tienen elegí el olor de los libros
porque es un olor
que nos gusta hay mucha evidencia es un
olor que está asociado a prácticas que
valoramos y es un olor al que le
atribuimos significado el olor del
conocimiento dice mucha gente una vez
elegido este olor lo investigó desde dos
puntos de vista por un lado su
composición química para entender cuál
es la fórmula y poder documentar la con
vistas a futuras reproducciones para eso
tomó muestras del aire
alrededor de los libros y las analizo en
el laboratorio utilizo ahí una técnica
que se llama cromatografía de gases de
espectrometría de masas que involucra
básicamente una nariz electrónica que
analiza los compuestos orgánicos
volátiles los compuestos químicos
responsables del olor y los identifica
pero un olor es una percepción y no
existe hasta que no hay una nariz para
olerlo y un cerebro para procesar las
señales por eso la segunda parte de mi
investigación es sensorial tiene que ver
con la percepción humana de ese olor que
palabras usamos para hablar de ese olor
cómo lo valoramos es agradable o
desagradable para eso utilizó varias
técnicas una de ellas se llama hissisni
fin y consiste como ven en poner la
nariz en un puerto de olor cerrar los
ojos y lograr un aislamiento sensorial
para concentrarse en el olfato
del instrumento uno a uno salen los
olores muy rápidos muchos olores por
minuto y uno tiene unos segundos para
describirlos es un ejercicio muy
interesante porque desafía este instinto
natural que tenemos de hablar de los
olores de forma personal a través de
nuestra experiencia por ejemplo huele a
la casa de mi abuela como científica me
interesa recolectar palabras que todo el
mundo puede entender incluso la gente
que nunca visitó la casa de mi abuela
aunque son muchos y documentar todas
estas palabras parece que fuera una
ciencia exacta casi las experiencias con
el instrumento varían a veces como el
popurrí me tocó las rosas y canelas
durante días y días y un compañero
recientemente tuvo que oler más de 40
muestras de retrete para una empresa de
desinfectantes una vez que tenemos estas
palabras combinamos la información para
formar una rueda de olor que recoge la
información química y la sensorial y
documenta este olor para el futuro hasta
ahí la teoría y parece que todo
funcionaría linealmente pero quiero
contarles un caso curioso que tuve
cuando
un olor en particular como compartía
elegí el olor de los libros porque nos
resulta familiar casi todos hemos salido
alguna vez un libro viejo uno podría
pensar que no hay mayor dificultad en
identificarlo y hablar de él pero qué
pasa cuando uno presenta este olor en un
bote sin etiqueta a más de 100 personas
y le pide que hablen que lo describan
que lo identifiquen ellos no sabían que
estaban oliendo el resultado es este la
mayor parte de la gente pensó que estaba
oliendo el chocolate y muchos dijeron
café para dar cuenta de la variedad de
experiencias que tenemos al oler hubo
quien dijo cenizas galletitas calcetines
sucios
lo cierto es que el chocolate y el café
tiene muchos compuestos en común con el
olor de los libros viejos por lo tanto
aunque las descripciones no hubieran
sido aceptadas las narices no se
equivocan o la mayoría
y recoger este tipo de descripciones es
parte del trabajo del marco que hemos
presentado para identificar analizar y
documentar olores con valor históricos
el próximo paso es crear un archivo de
olores accesible a todos como parte del
patrimonio
pero esto no es un trabajo que pueda
hacer nadie en un laboratorio porque
cuando hablamos de patrimonio hablamos
siempre de comunidad
si ustedes tuvieran que elegir tres o
cuatro olores para hablar de su vida
cuáles serían
qué olores los llevan a la infancia o
les hacen acordar a sus seres queridos
qué olores elegirían dejar a sus hijos y
a los hijos de sus hijos y finalmente
qué olores les gustaría rescatar del
olvido y guardar para siempre
si me preguntan a mí me gustaría
compartir con el niño del futuro un niño
quizás habituado al olor a plástico
tibio de los ordenadores la emoción de
tener 8 años y pararme por primera vez
frente a una biblioteca llena de libros
que olían a chocolate muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]